is this the dumbest way of solving a
mace we're starting at this orange point
here and we've got to find like how do
we get to the exit and my idea is that
i'm going to let a gas go here and then
you know at some point one of the atoms
of the gas
is going to reach the exit just by sheer
luck by luck yeah gonna be basically
moving randomly by do more and more
molecules than i would expect that it
would get when we get there faster i've
released a poisonous gas here and then
eventually like a canary dies over here
or something and here they go so quite
quickly they've spread out and they're
going
and they've got a few going around here
after a while this is the one that's
going to end up winning
it it got out there first
and this is the path that it took the
whole time
spends a bunch of wasted time in here
but here you go
you've got a solution it does some silly
things like going up here when it didn't
need to but you know this is basically
how to solve this maze
i love it matt i love the thought of
there was that one molecule there that
was destined for greatness and it it
didn't even know it would be the one all
right you know what it reminds me of
what sperm going to the egg
yeah will become a human it's totally
like that yeah and it's just pure luck
right i think there's various metaphors
that you can draw here like you know
everybody is just bumping around
randomly but the one person that you
know
became a billionaire or something they
wrote their autobiography how i got here
all the great decisions i made to beat
everybody
it was just random
it's a bit of a sort of inside joke and
that in computer science there's all
these different algorithms for doing
things efficiently and you know solving
mazes is a big
um example of like where you might apply
these algorithms like the lightning
algorithm we did in a previous right
exactly and that was you know finding
the shortest path like you find it
efficiently and what you get is the
shortest path
from the cloud that seeds the lightning
all the way down to the ground
but here well one thing i've done is
i've said the maze is actually going to
be this physical thing i don't i've
forgotten about the concept of like
cells of the maze and their adjacency
like where you can get to from each and
i've just said well there's a little
tiny molecule in there somewhere and
it's moving around it doesn't even know
when it's left one
cell and it's gone into the other it's
sort of a joke about
there might be like the most efficient
way to do something but hey this works
and maybe it's not that done this way
because it does work
right
you could either create a computer like
write all the code to solve this program
encode it in the transistors of the
computer or i'm saying you know just
release like a bad smell
you could maybe take this solution that
we found and improve it imagine that
this orange squiggly path is actually a
piece of string
just pull it tight and then it would be
a much better solution to the to the
maze
i know it would also be interesting to
see if you pulled that tight how long it
is yeah yeah yeah how much longer a path
did it take than it had to yeah one
thing about this this maze is that it
doesn't have any kind of loops around it
and that's kind of by design and that
means that works particularly well for
the string pulling type thing because
you're not going to get a knot anywhere
and you're just going to prob you'll get
the you will get the shortest path if
you pull it tight another thing you
could do is model
the interactions between molecules each
one is its individual little thing it
doesn't know about all the other
molecules and it's just moving around in
real life you might have some bouncing
of those and that's i guess is like
pressure and that would help it expand
out from the beginning and give you an
even better solution but obviously
that's harder to program because you
gotta am i bumping into this one am i
bumping into that one that would be
inefficient and then another thing you
could do is like
do some kind of fluid dynamics maybe so
if you had like some wind
just blow a hair dryer in here it might
help guide the molecules out and the air
from the
hair dryer has to escape out here
eventually because of pressure that
might give you a faster solution the
first step is figuring out how to
create a nice maze and i wanted that
property where there's a path between
every single point in the maze
and there's not going to be any loops
going to have a network of points on a
grid eventually i want to figure out
what are the walls but i'm actually
first going to think about what are the
paths that create the maze what i want
is to say that there's a path between
all points and i'm just going to just
start and create random ones so like if
i start drawing in things here what i'm
doing is i'm adding edges not randomly
i'll add an edge if it's not going to
create a loop anyway and i also want to
make sure that i reach every single
point you know maybe i go here and i
have
go down here
and then here these are paths and now
the walls
i could create walls that make these
valid paths but they're going to be on a
grid that's sort of offset from this one
so for example i better have a wall here
otherwise i should have had a line that
connected those two i needed a wall here
i'm just blocking the stuff off that
needs to be blocked but you can't go
from here to here without going around
here so there should be a wall
there as well likewise there should be a
wall here well here and now i'm just
going to enclose the whole thing and
then i'm going to add a little like goal
at the end maybe you start here
and so the maze is actually kind of an
artifact of me having found this network
of where you can go to from each point
which is called a tree tree is just a
network where there's no loops in it it
means that you end up having a nice maze
because if you have too many edges then
you don't have very many walls in the
code is i pick a width and a height and
i create this fully connected graph here
so that is i'm just saying like what is
the grid graph that means a graph where
everything is connected to thing to the
left above to the right and down but
just for some fixed rectangular size
and then i assigned
random
number to each of those edges and then i
asked mathematica to find the tree that
spans all of those points meaning it
visits all of the vertices there that
has the smallest total weight
on all the edges that's just a way for
it to come with a random maze each time
so for example this was a potential edge
i could have picked but maybe it had a
weight of a hundred that means it had a
cost basically of a hundred whereas this
one had one so that's why i picked you
know these these ones not that one so we
do that can you see we get this network
of all the paths that you can take from
each point i then have a nice guarantee
that i can put a goal here and a start
point there and i know there's going to
be a solution
because you can get to anywhere in the
maze from anywhere else so now i've just
got to figure out
the step i did here when i went from the
green pen to the brine pen what are the
walls that make make that not too much
more code and you get this picture here
so side by side here we've got the
network and we've got the walls that
should create that network you can kind
of see it looks right so for example
here we've got a path from this point
you can't get directly there you've got
to go up and around and down which is
correct your upper mind doesn't die so
that's how we've created the the walls
now all we've got to do is simulate
molecules inside this environment
is that hard or easy
uh it's just
yeah it is hard or easy there's a few
tricks you gotta do to make it not just
take forever on the other hand like i
just gotta make one animation and post
it on my twitter so i don't really care
if it takes too long so it's a bit of
one of those things where i could
optimize it and make it very fast or i
could you know
solve the maze in a dumbest way so i
switched over to python to start
stimulating the molecules here's a code
that does that imagine at each point i'm
trying to figure out i've got a molecule
here i'm just going to add a totally
random direction so each time it's going
to like take a tiny step in a new
direction and i just i need to make sure
that i'm not going to cross a wall i end
up here
and then if i go over here hey that's a
problem i'm now intersecting with the
wall so i've got so these aren't like
your famous bouncing balls that only
change direction when they hit a wall
they can change direction whenever they
want they're moving
every time step and that that is um
what's called brainy in motion or just a
random walk you know molecules dancing
around and then in real life that might
be because they're actually bouncing
into smaller molecules like these might
be some heavier gas in just the air
bumping into the small molecules of the
areas just making it look like hey
they're jittering around all the time
okay but i've got jittering around
randomly all the time but also i've got
to make sure don't go into a wall if it
looks like you're going to go into a
wall just reverse your direction and you
won't hit the wall so i program it so
that each point i know what are the
nearby walls around there
and then i do some math to say hey am i
actually intersecting so this block of
code here i'm saying i've got a point p
and i've got some sort of structure that
tells me what are the walls that i've
got going on and i'm saying am i going
to clip into the walls or not now i run
the code and it will just
keep on simulating again and again and
again i do them in big batches and then
the first batch that has a winner in it
i just stopped computation
so i'll show you what that looks like
but surely every batch will eventually
have a winner right but i only i do each
batch for a fixed for a maximum length
of time and then move on to the next
batch so there i've kind of
guessed i've said you know
10 000 steps or whatever is probably
going to be enough
or i i've kind of set a goal of and i'm
just going to simulate enough until i
get to
a solution because presumably if you do
an infinite number of batches eventually
you'll get one particle that just by
luck just perfectly this goes the exact
way uh totally i could for example
reject some of those solutions and say
ah that's not good enough and keep going
keep going keep going i'll leave my
computer running overnight if i just run
this hopefully it still works i'm
simulating
a batch of i think 64 points for
45 000 time steps and i've got a
progress bar saying this is how long
it's going to take we're doing some
screen recording to capture that so this
is much slower than it usually is
um but yeah i mean i would just
run this
leave it
um computer beeps when it's find
something and then i would bring it back
into mathematica and do the animation
let's look at how we do the like draw
everything and draw the back trace and
stuff once we've found a solution my
code there just outputs like here's all
the paths and i know that one of them
won in the end so first of all i've got
to figure out what what is the molecule
that won
and uh also i've got to just draw them
all going around and everything like
that i'm loading in solutions that were
found we ended up running 1856
molecules would be in the animation one
of them got to the end what i did was i
set it up so that this is the y equals
zero line so i find a solution just one
that reaches a negative y value that's
kind of an easy test for me and then
this code here is doing the animation
each molecule obviously just gets drawn
as a little point here and then we've
done that check to see which is the one
that reaches a negative y value and then
that's the one that we've realized is
the winner and we trace it back to the
beginning some people are like well how
do you know that one was gonna win like
how did you know to like put a circle
around it well actually i just kept
running this program and i logged
everything when i'm creating these
frames i'm not running the simulation
i'm just displaying the simulation the
simulation as you say is a file that has
logged all the other movements so you
could open up like you know a
spreadsheet or a log that would show the
winning molecules path
yeah that's right i basically started a
spreadsheet where i've got
1856 different molecules
and then for each one of them got 4500
xy coordinates just little massive loads
and loads of numbers
and i know my question next question is
don't you i want to see that i want to
see its log i want to see the log of the
winning bowl is that even possible to
find
the log of the winning ball yeah yeah
that's that's possible to find does he
have a name or a number that winning
ball yeah he's got an index so it's 1836
so if i look at the 1836
thing here
here are all the points that so the
starting point was one nine and then at
the end it's got a negative
y value that's his path so one
that's that doesn't look very
complicated for how wiggly his path was
i've cut i um four thousand four hundred
and eighty nine
other points
and you can see that because here is
this path you gotta be stuck there for a
while didn't they totally stuck there
pick another number we could we could
compare how it did how did ball wonder
yeah good good idea
red is the winner and blue is the
first one
so ball one got stuck up there and just
hung around there for ages yeah that's
right
volte
did that
both we did this and i said i kept
simulating kept simulating eventually i
got to the ball
at 1 836 in the last batch here's 1835.
did that each one is just totally random
so if i change this slider click here's
all the different
paths that were fined
let's see if we can find a really funny
one where he got stuck badly that's not
a great one looks like it came down i
was doing pretty straight line stuff and
then hung around in that area the other
one didn't get very far the scale is
changing because it's fitting right but
it's obviously just in the first one two
three four five six seven eight
nine ish
[Music]
that's fascinating
and
the winner
the winner looks
i mean it's still doing something pretty
dumb
look at these people in the gym
endlessly preening posing
and hopefully improving their bodies
go on big man
but do they ever give their brain a
workout
if so their mental gymnasiums should be
this
brilliant
these courses quizzes and collections of
problems are barbells for your brain
they're interactive carefully designed
and unlike a normal gym they're lots of
fun
so don't just sit there and let your
brain turn to mush give it a workout
with brilliant there's new content being
added all the time and you can get 20
off a premium subscription by going to
brilliant.org
numberphile you can also give brilliant
as a gift to other people
they're great people at brilliant and we
also appreciate that they love
supporting us here at numberphile so
thank you very much
you